welcome everybody and happy death loop
day
uh the embargo for death loop will have
lifted right now um i've had the game
for i think about three weeks uh but
naturally i'm not a reviewer so a lot of
people will be posting their reviews the
same time this video goes live but i
just wanted to answer the most common
question that i got after i made my
preview video where i did take in a
bunch of questions and answer them if
you have general questions that are not
related to the title of this video which
is how exactly the multiplayer works
then i'll leave a link for that video it
does cover a lot of the basics and goes
over every question you might have about
the game without any spoilers which i
think is very important before we even
get into any of this
the game comes out two days from now and
i just really wholeheartedly want to say
please
don't if you can avoid it you're on the
internet i get that
please try not to spoil it for yourself
i think everything that i discovered
throughout my time that i have spent
playing this game
has been more valuable because i was
figuring everything out myself and the
pieces are can be quite complicated so i
would highly encourage you not to look
at walkthroughs
um
follow the clues the game gives you and
and chase the trails yourself and you'll
have a much better time with it my
general impressions are that i think the
game is very good i really like it it's
really stylish great performances a very
interesting world a very unique concept
yes it's a lot like dishonored yes it
has elements of hitman but it really is
its own unique thing and as part of that
again
we will get to the question of the
headline very soon i do just want to
show off
i got um
this mailer that bethesda sent me which
uh huge thank you to bethesda for
providing me with a code they sent me
these three things so i got this box
tin rather that has a puzzle in it that
i assume is a full map of up damn and
i'm wondering if maybe the map has
something written on it that will help
me open the thing that is inside this
box which is
one of these
puzzle things but um i've not been able
to open it i tried to put arcane because
that's the right amount of letters but
sadly arcane did not work so something
is gonna let me open this which i assume
has a key inside it
because i also got
this locked box
um
this is like one of the coolest things
that i've ever been sent in terms of
like a press mail we also got this
little necklace here
as a an extra thing
so yeah i just thought that was awesome
i will try and figure it out at some
point
during the week how to get all of this
stuff open because right now i have no
idea so i've got to go on my own journey
of trying to avoid seeing anybody talk
about how they managed to do any of this
uh so welcome to death loop if i press x
right now
we will make me smaller as well
you will come straight to this menu
right here
where you have the option to break the
loop play as cult and experience all
that the loop has to offer if you select
this option that is you playing the
single player campaign and if you want
to you can turn the game offline so
you will just 100 be playing a single
player campaign no other players no
multiplayer you are good to just play
through the story as cult you will
occasionally
throughout uh any of the levels there
are four levels four times a day i would
say when i played through um i was
invaded by the second person here
juliana
who um you know is your antagonist does
talk to you plenty you will already know
her um pretty well before she actually
shows up in your world and she will try
and assassinate you the way the
multiplayer works um and there is more
depth to it than just this is that if i
were to press x to play as juliana right
now i would play online as juliana and
invade other players timelines hunt cult
and earn rewards so
i can choose to protect the loop and i
will invade somebody else's game
and i will go and kill colt so yes the
options are again that you can
choose to play completely offline you
will still be invaded uh juliana will
just be ai choose to make your game
friends only so that way only friends
can invade you um and i guess the mix of
that would probably be sometimes you'd
have ai juliana sometimes you would have
a friend and i think that's the option
that i find the most cool because then i
would know anytime i was invaded by a
real person that it's somebody on my ps5
friends list which i think is awesome or
you can have it open to everyone um and
i don't think that that would make her
invade your game with any more frequency
i'm sure there's a limit on how often
you will actually see juliana no matter
what but that does mean that instead of
it in theory ever being
uh ai depending on how many people are
playing the game at the time it will
always be
um a real person which should make it a
little bit more difficult especially
because you could both be at kind of
different points
in how far you've leveled up because
while cult does have his own level
system as you play through the single
player campaign and you level up
abilities and you can
improve uh any of your powers juliana
also has her own unique system so let me
hit on this and show you what this looks
like so before this i think i can't
access it because i've just done it
recently um there is like a little cut
scene that gives you a bit more context
before you actually get to the juliana
loadout menu here which looks very
similar to cults loadout menu for the
record like this is a slab that i
currently have equipped which is nexus
it links enemies very similar to
dishonored this is her permanent slab
which is masquerade
that allows you to exchange appearances
with someone else so that means if you
invade a cult if you invade somebody
else's game you wouldn't look like
juliana because all of the players are
going to know what she looks like she's
going to be very obvious you're going to
be worried about her killing you you
will know if someone's invaded though so
that's definitely handy and then we have
our weapon loadout here uh this is the
pt6 spiker which i actually do really
like um it shoots nails so it's one of
your quieter weapons and then you can
add trinkets to each of your weapons
here so this one has crackshot on it
which makes aiming down sights take less
time and depending on which of the
visionaries you've killed which is the
core of death loop they have trinkets
that are very specific to how they act
and what they do as characters which i
think is pretty neat um i don't have a
second trinket for this one and then you
can also have personal trinkets
so right now juliana has silver lining
which is add many bullets that hit you
to your own ammunition which is very
cool um tracker your charges do no
damage instead marking enemies with
focus in an expensive radius and which
yeah is a very handy way to figure out
where people are or where colt is and
then spring healed which i always have
equipped 100 of the time for either
character uh which gives you double jump
in mid-air a classic maneuver
so then uh if you are one of the
invaders obviously it is oh yeah you can
also change outfit i don't have any for
her though
but you can kind of see some of them
hidden in here so you can change the way
that she looks as well
um you can see it down here let me just
move myself real quick no that's the
game
that you have the option to
invade a random timeline
or invade a friend's timeline so
just as players who are playing as cult
can choose to let friends in or to let
anybody in you can choose to invade
anybody or just invade a friend um and
yeah you'd come equipped with this full
arsenal but also
with uh your hunter rank uh so this here
we're obviously hunter rank one right
now and there are a bunch of discovered
feats we have squatter survive for three
minutes during an invasion so that is
three minutes against whichever cult you
invade that probably wouldn't be that
hard be fun though
um sharp shooters shoot cult in the head
during an invasion kill cult during an
invasion kill cult with a proximity
charge during an invasion and you're
gonna get more points for any of the
purple ones which directly relates to
purple stuff being extra cool just like
a lot of other video games with
legendary stuff that you've played
so there are a bunch of these are
discovered and then down here a bunch of
undiscovered ones
so as you get further through
you will uh
unlock more of them and yeah this is
just a nice sorting menu
that'll give you different kind of
ideas of what to do slide into first
kill cult while sliding
unscathed win an invasion without
healing yourself that's that's a brutal
one
um
so it gives you extra objectives to do
in a way that i think is really neat um
and again yeah i wanted to explain this
just because i got the most questions
about it in my preview but technically
we weren't allowed to do it during the
preview event so i wasn't actually
allowed to try it and obviously if i
could i would show you what it looks
like right now um i could try to invade
random timeline you can just start the
matchmaking uh so this isn't an accurate
representation of how it will actually
be when people are playing the game um
because such a limited amount of people
have the game right now very good chance
that absolutely nobody else in the world
is playing it right now but yeah um did
get a lot of questions about it and that
is essentially it you will then
be matchmade and you will find a cult
who you will go and invade
that is the only part of this game that
is multiplayer it's basically this extra
mode that works like an assassin mode i
think assassin's creed did something
pretty similar where you can invade a
player's game uh demon souls does a kind
of similar thing oh we've found a match
oh there you go
okay um so we're jumping into a match
right now i'm gonna need to move my
webcam again to make sure i don't cover
any of the ui make me a little bit
smaller
so you can see exactly how this looks
which is awesome
okay i'm gonna move this over here so as
it sets you've invaded another timeline
hunt called protect the loop get
creative with your kills to maximize
your rewards um and thankfully when you
play as juliana unlike in the main game
other players won't bother with you
they're not worried about anything
you're doing
um if cult can get to this right here
he will be able to kick me out of his uh
of his world whoever is playing his cult
if they can do that then i will be
forcibly removed
um so i'm gonna use this right
now masquerade
and hopefully i should look different
and then i just have to track down where
the hell colt is
and it's generally a pretty safe bet
that he's going to want to come for the
antenna
but
uh
i don't know where he is right now so
whoever i'm hunting oh there we go
is going to be just trying to do their
their base objectives um and this place
is usually pretty well trip mined up so
if i get lucky
you could have already taken some damage
did he go for the antenna
okay we found him
there he is there is colt has he seen me
yet i don't know
hello mate where are you going what are
you doing
he's shooting other people right now so
i'm gonna let him do that
because he you know he's got the higher
ground up over there right
okay
i reckon we can run up behind him pretty
well
he did hack that drone so that's why
that drone just shot me okay let's go
he had a way better weapon than me
but in any case the point there is uh
you'll you'll basically see exactly how
that works so
whoever was playing just then had it
open to anyone so i was able to invade
their game they took me out um they can
also one thing that's very cool for you
if you do um have a giuliana invade you
is that
uh
you can actually sometimes get a slab
off of her so you can upgrade very
important stuff just by attacking
juliana
um
and now i have 25 points here if i tab
over here
we got because we died during an
invasion you'd love to see it and yeah
that's essentially it so um yes it is
not a multiplayer game there is just a
multiplayer mode that's a very
you know it's it's instant pvp um you
can both level up and you don't really
know what you're going into
i've had versions of events much more
successful than that naturally and ones
that do end that fast
and it is a really fun addition to a
single player game that mostly impresses
me because it works
with the theme and the story actually
very well
it's a very smart integration
but that's it i had someone ask me if
the game was like gotham knights like
that was the impression they got from
this hint at multiplayer they thought
that it was juliana and cult playing
together and like swapping out no you
you really do play a single player
campaign as cult it is very narrative
focused very story driven very much like
dishonest where you find out about these
people that you have to assassinate um
the gameplay itself is much different to
that but that is the the core of what it
is is
taking out these eight visionaries
and this other person who was also very
invested in the loop juliana will invade
you either as a player or as ai and that
is also
tied into the story established in the
story an ongoing thing that is actually
quite fun to watch play out so i hope
that answers the question um yeah death
loop embargoes up now so you will see
reviews popping up everywhere and um
yeah my main takeaway is that i really
enjoyed it i thought it was awesome and
i have to figure out
what all this stuff is and how to open
these things at some point
if i had the setup to do a puzzle
building stream i would do it but i
don't know how i would do that but yeah
i'm sure i will stream the game at some
point as well um
i'm super into it so thank you everyone
for watching i hope that answered the
last remaining question that i seem to
get about this game i will see you guys
next time